I also think traditional learning
environments aren't suited for most men
right like it's not typical I mean we
didn't do this for a long time to have
you also employers are also saying that
college graduates are not prepared
adequately for you know working and
everything yeah it's useless it's just a
holding pattern I mean at one point
academics like universities and schools
they really were sort of interesting
places they prepared you to work but I
don't think that's true anymore I mean I
went to a Ford University and I was
grateful for the experience but I knew
so many people who enrolled in Master's
programs because they didn't want to be
adults yet yeah and they also say that
college graduates lack critical thinking
skills because they're taught to
memorize I mean that's the American
education system especially in college
you're not rewarded for thinking
critically and analytically